Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
und ich muss erst noch mal socken anziehen kurz
hoffentlich jetzt hier nicht das runterschmeiß wenn ich da beides herz auf hab aber es wird
schon irgendwie hinhauen so so
1.2. ihr seid weder 1. noch 2. wobei vpn at landis könnte tatsächlich 1. sein aber
mittlerweile sind 26 leute da und 1 finger man ist auf jeden fall minuten später
definitiv nichts weiter zu mal tommy schon vorher was geschrieben hat fake news leute
hier los gibt es news zum neuen job ja habe ich gestern eine stunde drüber geredet im stream
also insofern ich werde ich erzählen aber nachher noch was ich jetzt gibt ja immer gibt
ja immer freilich ich werde das e im stream noch 20 mal erzählen
ja ist richtig war kurz die vm an und reboote das ding mal das habe ich gestern vergessen
das stimmt das stimmt das habe ich gesehen man sieht es hier wird sicherweise nicht aber
drüben in der stream vorschau sehe ich also ich habe keine ahnung warum ich hier nicht
sehen mit ersten post und drüben sieht man wahrscheinlich weil ich hier nicht eingeloggt
bin kann man erklären warum sich dieses dumme one drive immer wieder startet und ich das
hier ist barclosen muss gut weil es von schreif ist da muss man sich glaube ich nicht so viel
gedank machen das ist halt rot bei design ja mal gucken aus dem autostart ja wie wie
aus dem autostart entfernen sagst mir autostart im klassischen sinne gibt es ja offiziell
unter windows elf nicht mehr es gibt jetzt in meinem geht immer noch man muss den ordner
halt von hand aufmachen im task manager gibt es den autostart das ist mir neu wo ich will
kein extra tool ich will das so ausschalten ach da naja und da gibt es jetzt one drive
ne natürlich nicht ach doch da ist es doch one drive dieselbe bäm nice ha systema chat
der chat kennt sich aus mit sowas könnte klatsch windows admins werden sehr nice ist
davon habe ich keine ahnung ich bin ja auch ein senior linux engineer ich habe ja auch
keine ahnung von windows das titel ist schon schon ernst gemeint
ob die vm angeht ich habe wie oft habe ich jetzt bitteschön schon auf do not show message
again geklickt 50 mal jetzt gucken wir mal ob wir jetzt nachschieben müssen oh ja oh
yes ok ok so viel ist es jetzt nicht man jaro hat mal random wieder irgendwelche komischen
pakete replace dann weiß sie was sie schreit was sie da treiben ok gibt nichts na gut dann
was zum also leute die punkte hier an der stelle die sollten eigentlich nicht so dick
sein ich habe falsch gescrollt jetzt gehen sie auch wieder die logik muss man echt nicht
verstehen teilweise gut da kann jetzt mindestens nichts für kein rett hat zertifikat man
ne ich habe gar ich habe weder ein rett hat zertifikat noch ein ubuntu sorry sorry nicht
ubuntu sondern wir müssen es wir müssen jetzt schon korrekt aussprechen ich habe
weder ein ubuntu noch rett hat noch ein suzzi könnte ja kaum noch schlimmer sein zertifikat
ich habe auch kein lp ich habe nichts gemacht in der richtung sehe ich auch den sinn drinne
nicht wenn ich ehrlich bin ne wozu wozu sollte ich irgendwelche ich habe einen cc na gemacht
vor 14 jahren oder so aber das interessiert im prinzip auch noch nie jemand interessiert
ja das stimmt schon vor allem wenn es irgendwelche consulting läden sind die dich weiter verkaufen
können teurer habe ich letztens gelernt wenn du zertifikate hast wenn man spaß anzelt gibt
es ernsthaft leute gibt es jemand der spaß und zertifikaten hat gibt es jemand der das
gerne macht ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen dass leute gibt es gern machen also ich musste
in letzter zeit ab und zu mal so eine escher schulung mitmachen und das ist an lange weile
echt kaum also kaum zu überbieten die escher schulung sind so extrem langweilig vor allem
weil microsoft ja auch der klaut der schlauen ansicht ist dass diese ganzen escher schulungen
immer gleich gehalten werden müssen mit der gleichen powerpoint mit dem gleichen durchgeklickt
das heißt selbst wenn du jemand hast der eigentlich ganz gut solche schulungen halten könnte
der darf gar nicht das richtig machen und es ist microsoft logik das verstehe ich nicht
die müssen dieses powerpoint zeug durch rattern letztes bei einer schulung gesehen gehört
besser gesagt dass es doch deutlich besser ist streamst du schon von dem neuen pc aus
chat was meint ihr hat sich da seit gestern was geändert kann korrekt ist immer noch der
alte pc das hat es früher bei mir auch nicht gegeben ohne scheiß ich hätte früher nie im
leben einen neuen rechner eine woche bei mir hier im büro stehen lassen und ohne ihn als
main rechner zu verwenden aber ich habe in der zwischenzeit noch was dran gemacht ich
habe noch eine ich habe noch eine weitere sata ssd eingebaut noch zwei weitere m2 ssd
richtig richtig genau daran erkennst du es daran erkennst du es und ich habe den ram
takt ich habe jetzt mal ordentlich jetzt gebenchmarked und stabilitäts test gemacht guckt was alles
dass das alles passt ich habe jetzt die ganzen sachen zum größten teil rüber kopiert die
ich brauche also also sachen was ich brauche also alle sachen die halt nice to have sind
ja die ich jetzt nicht unbedingt gigabyteweise backappen will ich habe zum beispiel die ganzen
vm images rüber kopiert oder so wenn ich die verlieren würde wäre es nicht schlimm
aber wozu soll ich das alles neu einrichten ja ich habe die ganzen vm images jetzt rüber
kopiert auch die ganzen steam library origin bei origin ist ja nicht mehr origin app ist
es jetzt ja alle möglichen sachen die man ja videoaufnahmen rüber kopiert die ich noch
brauche für neue videos halt die ganzen geschichte sind halt schon ein paar gigabyte kommt da
kommt da zusammen du du du du du du was ist eigentlich die interne bezeichnung für deinen
neuen job senior agile cloud solutions mindestens mindestens das was im titel steht das was
im stream titel steht selbst dankeschön für den sub wer es hier noch mal schaut der samuel
ist am start porgas leute sonst keiner ich sag es ich kann ich sag ich sag es euch heute
nur einmal im stream und dann noch zwei weitere mal wenn ihr den prime sub habt dann guckt
dass ihr den prime sub nicht verfallen lasst und mir ist vollkommen wurscht ob ihr mir
den prime sub gebt oder ob ich den jemand anderem gebt aber überweist bezos nicht die
2,50 € schreibst du am kernel rum nö heute nennt man alles engineer das hat mit kernel
nix zu tun ja du hast schon recht wenn man es ganz streng streng genau nimmt dürften
eigentlich linux engine wirklich nur die kernel entwickler sein aber das heute eine ganz normale
ganz normale berufsberatung ganz normale job nicht wirklich berufsberatung ganz normale
job bezeichnung das ist im prinzip das gleiche wie wenn einer linux server admin ist oder
system administrator oder sowas in der richtung das kommt im prinzip ziemlich oft gleiche
raus oftmals vom job her ob das jetzt ein devops engineer ist ein server admin ein linux
engine system administrator oder dinger die in die richtung gehen das nimmt sich oftmals
vom aufgabengebiet nicht so viel also es ändert sich natürlich drastisch das aufgabenbild
je nachdem in welcher firma du bist weil da kann es komplett anders sein aber wie die
es jetzt einzeln nennen ist eigentlich vollkommen egal filet dankeschön drei monate abo falle
sehr gut exzellent erst mal direkt bei redhead anfangen ich habe ein kollege aktuell der
hat früher mal bei redhead gearbeitet der fand das gar nicht so dolle berater du bist
einer ein konsultant zu was kann man dich denn konsultieren
achja ich mach mal die vm ach nee ich hab die vm ja schon an lull
boah leute ich bin heute irgendwie nicht so richtig fit ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt high
iq sachen im stream machen kann zwei stunden lang
merkt das gerade jetzt wo ich den wo ich den stream angemacht hab also jetzt nicht krank
oder so irgendwie weil es schon so spät ist oder so keine ahnung ob ich das jetzt auf
die reihe kriege ja das müsstest du das müsstest du ihn fragen das weiß ich nicht
ja warum hast du ok das müssen wir jetzt mal besprechen warum hast du linux als mainsystem
und nicht windows als mainsystem und linux in der vm hast du gar nichts mehr was du unter
windows benutzen musst oder lohnt sich einfach nicht weil das so selten ist ja gut dann ist
gut ihr leute ich würde das auch gerne machen ohne scheiß ich würde gerne von heute auf
morgen wenn das runterschmeißen die sache ist plus die ehrlich gesagt so wirklich scharf
auf hauptsächlich linux benutzen bin ich auch nicht weil es gibt keine oberfläche
unter linux die mir gefällt ich will nicht sagen dass mir die windows oberfläche gefällt
ganz im gegenteil ja die windows oberfläche ist auch grausam aber das einzige was ich unter
linux gerne verwende ist i3 das war es und i3 ist ja keine wirkliche kein wirklicher
desktop keine richtige oberfläche die drei ist ja im prinzip einfach nur eine leiste
und fenster im fullscreen was kann es jetzt das gibt jetzt wenig an i3 was einem nicht
gefallen kann ehrlich gesagt ich meine fenster im fullscreen die leiste könnte man sagen
hier oben ist hässlich aber ansonsten das ist einfach anwendung im fullscreen fertig
ohne was anderes auf dem bildschirm also aber die ganzen desktop umgebungen unter linux
gefallen mir gar nicht also genau mag ich überhaupt nicht kde mag ich ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht xfce ist mir auch zu zu zusammen gewurstet ist irgendwie nix dabei was mir
gefällt ich habe alles schon mal reingeguckt in alles früher habe ich eine weile eh wie
ist das e17 oder so verwendet zwar aber auch ist auch alles alles müll wie gesagt das
ist nicht wirklich besser als unter windows es ist auch müll dafür ist das betriebssystem
unten drunter deutlich besser
hast du bei der arbeit auch web anwendung erstellt und kratzen so mit menü und so also
das war nicht meine hauptaufgabe auf der arbeit web anwendung zu erstellen aber ja ich habe
auf der arbeit auch schon die eine oder andere web anwendung erstellt hauptsächlich kleine
sachen für irgendwelche tools ja oder zum zum abkürzen von irgendwelchen sachen also
keine ich habe jetzt nicht irgendwie riesen interne web anwendung alleine programmiert
elementary mag ich auch nicht ist so auf mac auf mac gemacht aber nicht dass es mir ich
weiß nicht es ist irgendwie es gibt wenig wenig desktop oberfläche die mir gefallen
ganz im ernst so plötzlich so blöd das klingt ja also ich ich würde gerne hier uns als
betriebssystem verwenden die normalen linux des tops gefallen mir nicht die windows oberfläche
hier jetzt unter windows 10 da muss ich sagen die ist mir fast noch lieber als die meisten
linux des tops mir ist linux als betriebssystem deutlich lieber an die windows oberfläche
nicht so rein von dieser von dieser oberfläche also von der von den sachen die man 90 prozent
am tag braucht ist mir das dann eigentlich sogar noch lieber mal abgesehen davon dass
dieses wir reden jetzt nicht von dieser verkackten settings app und sowas aber selbst das das
ist auch müll und so blöd es jetzt klingt wisst ihr was wenn ich mir so überlege eigentlich
hat mir von allen sachen die ich bisher verwendet habe bin aus xp am besten gefallen das lag
zum größten teil aber aus der kombination das lag aus also es lag schon mal von haus
aus dran dass die kombination unter windows xp zum letzten mal stimmig war ja also das
gesamte design das ist das war irgendwie stimmig wenn da auch schon ganz uralte komponenten
drin waren ja ich ich mochte die farbwahl das war halt sehr sehr bunt ja fand ich jetzt
schlecht und was ich an windows xp richtig gut fand ist das konnte man auch wirklich
komplett sieben wie man wollte da gab es ja alle möglichen tools dafür das fand ich
nice also rein von der oberfläche muss ich sagen hat mir persönlich wenn aus xp tatsächlich
am besten gefallen besser als die ganze linux des tropf besser als die neuen winos version
mit ich mein zu meck will ich jetzt nicht so viel sagen weil ich habe nie wirklich täglich
mehrere stunden jemals meck verwendet ich bin da ab und zu mal dran und klick da ab
und zu mal rum und probiere das ab und zu mal ein bisschen aus aber nicht so das haut
das schockt mich jetzt aber auch nicht deswegen bin ich wahrscheinlich im endeffekt unter
linux auch bei e3 hängen geblieben weil da hast du einfach schlicht nachher du hast
ja kein desktop guck leute es gibt kein desktop also kannst hier nichts ich mache rechts
klick ja du hast kein desktop ich weiß das geht mit trick 17 kann man ja auch du hast
kein desktop du hast nichts du hast im prinzip eine leiste du hast ja du hast ja auch keine
task leiste oder so du hast eine leiste mit virtuellen desktops und das war es und auf
jedem desktop hast du eine oder mehrere anwendungen im fullscreen gibt es gibt eigentlich nur
fullscreen ok man kann wenn man will auch anwendungen als fenster machen aber will man meistens
nicht deswegen bin ich wahrscheinlich bei e3 hängen geblieben einfach weil es so minimalistisch
ist dass es einfach nix gibt was mir auf zack gehen kann zu kubernetes da gibt es ja auch
die unterschiedlichen aussprachen ja kubernetes kubernetes kubernetes was ich alles gehört
habe kubernetes oder so wie es die amis sagen gibt es gibt es alle möglichen dinger das
ist ein äußerst vielfältiges mein checkmk ist das einzige hier dran was relativ überschaubar
noch ist ja die zwei sachen das sind ja fässer ohne boden ja das stimmt das hat er auch erzählt
wie gesagt das müsste man ihn fragen ich habe keine ahnung weiß ich was sie dann machen
hast du schon was mit esp 32 esp home gemacht ja habe ich kannst du etwas zum einlernen
empfehlen kommt drauf an was du machen willst also es macht eigentlich kein sinn esp home
zu lernen in dem sinn also du kannst dir die esp home konfig angucken wenn du einen konkreten
anwendungsfeld hast ja man kann in esp home ich weiß man kann in line c++ machen aber
ganz im ernst normales c++ fackt mich schon ab aber wie schlimm ist es erst c++ embedded
in jammel leute also wer das macht der ist wirklich dem ist wirklich nicht mehr zu helfen
direkt den klo runter spülen aller c++ embedded in jammel ich glaube es geht los das habe
ich mir nicht ausgedacht das kannst du da wirklich machen aber ansonsten wenn es direkt supportet
wird ist das nice ich habe dabei ich habe damit mal meinen stromzähler ausgelesen mit
esp home ich mag ja ehrlich gesagt eher das motor direkt drauf flaschen und gut ist aber
das motor kann halt bei weitem nicht so viele geräte ansprechen wie esp home also wenn
man den fall hat das esp home was gut supportet man kann das damit machen warum nicht ansonsten
wenn irgendwas ausgefallen ist hast bastel ich lieber die firme selbst auch wenn es c++
ist c++ ist wirklich wir haben sie im stream schon gemacht ist wirklich ein abartigkeit
kaum zu überwinden i find es so sinn aber das fand ich tatsächlich ganz okay also
es gab ja linux mint eine weile ich weiß gar nicht ob das immer noch so ist gab es
ja als mate und als cinnamon edition gibt es immer noch guck und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen von den ganzen linux desktops ist mir wahrscheinlich mate am liebsten auch wenn
ich den ich hauptsächlich verwenden würde aber wenn ich einen verwenden müsste dann
würde ich wahrscheinlich am ehesten noch mate desktop verwenden ja cinnamon war ganz
okay ich kann aber ich muss ehrlich sagen so wirklich richtig gut dran erinnern kann
ich mich gar nicht aber das ist das mit diesem nervigen startmenü wo man links und rechts
kläden ist was anderes geht geht bestimmt auch klar kann man alles verwenden aber wie
gesagt so wirklich scharf drauf das zu benutzen bin ich alles nicht dann am liebsten wahrscheinlich
sogar noch mate oder wenn es sein muss xf ce aber am liebsten ist mir wirklich so ein desktop
ohne desktop einfach eine leiste oben fenster fullscreen fertig kde egal in welcher ausgabe
mag ich kde nicht auch wenn ich das framework cool finde was unten drunter ist gerade für
desktop cross platform anwendung das ist eigentlich so konkurrenzlos das beste was es gibt leider
zum größten teil c++ was es fast unusable macht aber gut aber kde mag ich nicht das
ist tatsächlich so es gibt viele leute die setzen sich auseinander mit welcher welcher
datei manager ist der beste so der mit split view der ohne split view der beste datei manager
ist einfach ein terminal und dann machen was man machen will wie lässt wie lass ich das
nebenher laufen ist ganz einfach was meinst du jetzt ist linux oder wie das ist vor allem
ein workstation auf dem zweiten windows desktop guck nur dass es im fullscreen ist und wenn
das nicht auffällt so richtig weil ich das ausgeplandet habe ich tippe ich tippe hier
einfach raus aus der vm und switch den virtuellen desktop ich habe hier mehrere windows desktops
und ich habe mich jetzt schon so dran gewöhnt dass ich die den shortcut von vm wer maus
raus und bin aus desktop switchen immer so quasi zeitgleich drücke deswegen deswegen
sieht das so so seamless aus ja die sind auch geil die ist ja prometheus was ich auch gemerkt
habe bei der aussprache was die amis richtig fertig macht ist da ist der deutsche vorname
uwe juvi und so uwe können die überhaupt nicht aussprechen die amis alles kannst du
knicken ich bin da wo ich bin auch dabei eugen ja das kann ich auch nicht versagen was sagen
hier an jugend oder so eugen eugen eugen ja so weit von der realität ist also so weit
ist doch gar nicht weg kfc kfc kann ich dann mehr essen das problem bei kfc ist also ich
ich hab ich hab das die letzten male und ist schon paar jahre her aber ich hab es überhaupt
nicht vertragen das ist eigentlich einfach kfc ist nicht einfach nur fettig sondern
dass es wirklich tropfelt ihr kennt mich ne also es ist nicht so als hätte ich jetzt
hier ein problem ein bisschen was fettiges zu futtern oder so aber kfc ist mir zu krass
fertig das tropft schon so richtig also diese panade von kfc kann gar nicht mehr fett aufnehmen
schon die ist quasi 100 prozent gesättigt ja den findest du hier den einzigen den den
einzigen den skip davon den senior linux engineer es gibt es gibt weltweit gibt niemand mehr
sonst deswegen ist jetzt die einmalige chance natürlich auch hier seinen prime sub dazu
lassen sonst gibt es das nirgendswo wobei man da sagen muss das ist auf twitch tatsächlich
gar nicht so weit hergeholt mit sonst gibt es das nirgendswo weil das zeug was wir hier
auf twitch machen ist schon recht nische ja aber es gibt auch wirklich nicht viele die
sowas treiben auf twitch selbst wenn man mal in technology science technology und und programming
und so guckt da hast du ein paar spiele entwickler du hast ein paar grafik zeug machen und sowas
creative aber so kram hier gibt es eigentlich fast gar nicht wird daraus dankeschön 13 monat
subscription bock gerade auf deutsch das stimmt das stimmt ja da gibt es echt nicht viel
brain lag sehr guter name machst du mal einen dj stream wie kommst du darauf als könnte
ich irgendwie ansatzweise was in der richtung macht wie findest du es eigentlich dass sachen
wie net netz der tippe catern dafür ganz ehrlich es wird eine weile dauern wenn ich mich dran
gewöhnt habe ich mache auch immer netz der tulpen weil ich einfach dran gewöhnt bin
kann man sich auch gut merken ich werde mich wahrscheinlich erst daran gewöhnen wenn es
default ist und ich das andere nicht mal verwenden kann standardmäßig genauso wie if konfig
leute haben wir noch if konfig hier if konfig hört sich jetzt auch ein bisschen falsch an
ja aber noch if konfig user also auch leute die heute noch if konfig nach installieren oder
unter debian ist es ja net utils 2 oder irgendwie sowas dass man nach genau if konfig ja stimmt
das ist tatsächlich in deutschland kein allzu cleveres bezeichnung für einen kommando wenn
ein kommando ss heißt unterlinux das ist negativ vorbehaftet stimmt ja den gibt es auch noch
kannst du mir über meine art installation auf art by the way du musst vorher erst einmal
allen leuten erzählen dass du artstellungsverwendest dann dann vielleicht was gibt es da also was
willst du was willst du ist ich meine artstellungsinstallation mit dem install script ist mittlerweile doch
relativ easy
machst du mal ein buber stream woher wollt ihr wissen dass ich jetzt hier nicht halbnackig
vom rechner sitze ich hatte eine sehr spezielle frage für ein projekt das ich angehen würde
da du bei einem provider gearbeitet hast kannst du mir das vielleicht beantworten wo kann
ich dich am besten fragen hier jetzt hier im chat
hallo wo bloß noch mal eine frage zu dein bewerbungsdokument kannst du ein beispieldokument
für eine skillliste zeigen ja
das ist meine skillliste kein witz also ich weiß sieht billig aus ja und das einfach
als markdown rennen und fertig
so so sieht meine skillliste aus genauso also ohne mist 1 2 punkte habe ich noch geändert
aber ich habe das original so dahin geschickt so wie man das hier sieht jetzt
ich glaube die große und kleine schreibung habe ich noch gefixt manche sachen habe ich
noch ein bisschen geändert vor dem was drin steht aber so habe ich das dahin geschickt
fertig jetzt sind ausgedruckt sind das drei seiten
stellen die mal ein chat hab nö warum
so würde ich das so würde ich das ich meine bei mir das funktioniert
das habe ich genau so genau so habe ich das mitgeschickt und hochgeladen
ja das kann man schon machen aber ich verwende ungern office anwendung außer wenn es sein
muss die einzige office anwendung die ich regelmäßig verwendet habe in den letzten
jahren über das powerpoint weil man da manchmal was zeigen muss ja nö ich habe das einfach
als pdf geschickt drei seiten fertig was so musst du mit google cloud machen ich weiß
gar nicht ob ich ob wir heute weitermachen soll ich bin irgendwie nicht so nicht so high
IQ mehr weiß ich ob wir heute weitermachen ja ich
habe mir schon überlegt was wir machen und es ist auch nicht so schlimm dass in den letzten
stream nicht dabei gewesen seid weil ich hätte die sachen heute eh noch mal ein bisschen
ordentlich gemacht und bisschen erweitert und das ganze ja ich hätte also eigentlich
hatte ich heute folgendes vor wir machen unser unser vm setup in der cloud noch mal neu mit
ordentlichen bezeichnungen so dass es ordentlich europa und in usa aufgebaut wird dass wird
es auch in gruppen machen dass man dann ordentlich drauf load balenzen kann dass es sich automatisch
beim monitoring registriert und so was habe ich schon alles überlegt ich habe heute morgen
sogar noch ein paar polumi tutorials gelesen aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das heute
auf die reihe kriege heute abend noch ich bin irgendwie schon ein bisschen so flach
wie wir haben es früher flasche leer ich glaube ich glaube das machen wir heute doch nicht
glaube ich löscht das mal wieder aus dem titel beste möglichkeit hardware grams zu
lernen was weiß was verstehst du unter hardware grams so was wie sp 2866 sp 32 oder microcontroller
arduino zeug oder was ist hardware grams ich meine hardware grams kann ich mir wirklich
alles bedeuten
nee noch nicht
bei mir wäre die skillliste viel kürzer aber soll ich auch so eine ganze skillliste
bei bewerbungen raus schicken die nicht so viel mit den sachen zu tun so bei irgendwelche
produkte ich mein warum nicht ganz ehrlich da können sie durchblättern und sich die
sachen angucken die ihnen gefallen ich würde das nicht unbedingt jetzt also ich kann ich
kann jetzt nur aus eigener erfahrung sagen also ich habe das so gemacht ich habe lebenslauf
hingeschickt da habe ich nur ganz grob so die haupt die wichtigsten über kategorien von
den aufgaben die ich bei der jeweiligen firma hatte reingeschrieben und dann habe ich hinten
dran noch dreiseitige skillliste gehängt so kollege von mir dass ich auch beworben hat
und den sie auch genommen haben der hat einen lebenslauf gemacht er war drei seiten lang
und er war viel ausführlicher und hat auf der letzten seite noch alle kurse und zertifikate
draufgeschrieben kann man sicherlich auch so machen
aber warum nicht ich fand gerade das gute an so einer skillliste dass du alles möglich
reinschreiben meinst guck mal ich habe da auch so viel reingeschrieben was mit der sache
nix zu tun hat ich meine beworben habe ich mich auf quasi sowas hier in der richtung
ja auf sowas hier in der richtung habe ich mich beworben also entweder wieder devops
engineer linux server administrat cloud so was hier habe ich mich drauf aber ich habe
trotzdem den ganzen anderen krempe noch reingeschrieben ja ich habe ich habe jahrelang monitoring
zeug gemacht mich käme die cloud umgebung aus ich habe auch relativ breit ahnung was
software entwicklung frontend backend angeht ein bisschen datenbanken iot geschichten und
die ganzen tools im netzwerk das ist nichts was direkt was mit meinem job zu tun hat auf
den ich mich beworben habe ich mein warum nicht ja mein schad hat nix
den sagt ich habe eine ds lite internetanbindung bavauder von ofields batman ergo kann ich
von außen nicht auf mein netzwerk zugreifen weil ipv4 über ipv6 getolbert das ist korrekt
wäre es möglich via udp udp hole punching und einem austauschserver eine klein zu ja
das geht
das geht also ich kann dir ehrlich gesagt nicht so hundertprozentig aus dem kopf sagen
wie mit welchen schritten und sonst wie aber dadurch dass du beispielsweise voib telefonie
auch über ds lite machen kannst und das geht ja klein zu kleint in der regel es sei denn
es ist sowas wie skype oder discord oder so und so jetzt geht da klein zu klein die verbett
der verbindungsaufbau geht über ein vermittlungsserver und die daten gehen dann von klein zu klein
das geht das kannst du machen ich meine es macht ja keinen unterschied ob du carrier
kreaten hat hast oder doppelt ist natt bei dir daheim das kommt ja im endeffekt aufs
gleiche raus bei den problemen die es zu lösen gibt ja das wird das das würde prinzipiell
funktionieren aber du kannst ja auch noch einfacher machen
ja du kannst entweder einen tunnel schon einen fertigen tunnel benutzen die es schon
fertig gibt oder du mietest die irgendwie so eine 3 euro 50 vm im monat und machst irgendwie
einen vpn oder oder halt wenn gar nichts hilft ein ssh tunnel wo du globalen port weiterleitest
oder so du brauchst ja im prinzip nur eine ipv4 end endpunkt im internet dann kannst
es weiter leihen es wird schon seinen kund haben warum er das nicht macht ja wenn du
ipv6 nehmen kannst dann ist einfach das stimmt weil ipv6 geht auch ohne tunnel aber ich gehe
mal davon aus es hat seinen grund warum es nicht nicht geht
was hast du den neuen job ja ich habe den vertrag hier zum unterschreiben ich werde
das nächste woche nächste woche bringe ich das nach frankfurt unterschrieben zurück
und dann werde ich die kündigung auch gleich abgeben das anschreiben hast du sehr knapp
gehalten ich habe kein anschreiben geschrieben ich habe ich habe kein anschreiben geschrieben
also die die sachen wo ich mich beworben habe die folgendermaßen das erste mal hat mich
einem stream jemand angeschrieben also waren ja insgesamt nur vier sachen das erste mal
hat mich jemand angeschrieben und ums lange story kurz zu machen das ist nichts geworden
erst hatte ich korona dann hat er korona oder mein ansprechpartner dort und dann das hat
nicht funktioniert das andere hat mich ein ex-kollege gefragt ob ich nicht hin will habe
ich mir angehört fand ich nice war ich mir soweit auch schon einig dann kam noch ein
anderer ex-kollege aus frankfurt hat mich gefragt zwischenzeitlich habe ich ein paar
andere mails und so bekommen also ohne scheiß ich habe kein anschreiben geschrieben das
einzige was ich machen musste ist um die dass die der prozess eingehalten wird ich musste
halt meine bewerbung offiziell bei bei allen noch einreichen ja und das habe ich dann eigentlich
nur überlegt gerade ich habe nirgendwo anschrieben anschreiben dabei gab das habe ich immer
geschickt entweder an die personalabteilung oder halt über irgendein portal da habe ich
dann skillliste lebenslauf hochgeladen später noch ein paar zeugnisse was war es fertig
ich habe kein anschreiben geschrieben keine ahnung also gut wenn das bei dir funktioniert
nee wenn du carrier create natas bringt ja den eigenen router auch gar nichts wo davon
macht nat auf ihrer seite das ist egal ob du eine fritz box hast die du selbst vertreibst
oder wo davon gut ach du hast in deinem lebenslauf naja doch doch doch also nee nee ich habe keine
ich habe keine zeile für IT-kenntnisse im lebenslauf ich habe hingeschrieben keine
ahnung 2000 ich sag mal 2007 bis 2010 oder so habe ich hingeschrieben bla bla bla internet
provider und da habe ich dann geschrieben betrieb hochverfügbare linux systeme betrieb
monitoring systeme und sowas habe ich da reingeschrieben ich habe da wirklich nur ganz grob die aufgabengebiete
reingeschrieben und keine skills und details genau und das habe ich alles in meine skillliste
reingeschrieben deswegen war der lebenslauf kurz und die skillliste 3 seiten lang
wie schreibst du eine kündigung mit welchem inhalt das kann ich dir zeigen
was wird da drinnen stehen sehr geehrte damen und herren hiermit kündige ich ordentlich
und fristgerecht meinen arbeitsvertrag zum nächsten möglichen zeitpunkt dieses nach
meinen berechnungen und einhaltungen der kündigungsfrist der 31.3.2023 bitte bestiegen sie mir
den erhalt dieser kündiger und das beendigungsdatum schriftlich ich bitte sie mir ein qualifiziertes
berufsförderes arbeitsverteidiger auszustellen bitte zusammen einmal bedanke ich mich tatsächlich
mit freundlichen grüßen mag so aus ja nämlich das schreibe ich da rein
ja zehn jahre zehn jahre plus dann haben wir es
nice big stonks gibt es bei ihm jetzt ja und open source er hat er hat sich selbst open
source mittlerweile davon fragen wie alt du bist ja ich bin 38 aber das ist gut wenn
es bei dir hast hast du wirklich am letzten tag letzten arbeitstag so dieses jahr noch
mal gehalsverhandlung gemacht so nach dem motto jungs wenn ihr wollt dass ich nächstes
jahr noch da bin oder wie hast du das gemacht richtig boomer wobei mit 38 ist man ja eigentlich
eher so zwischen summa und boomer also am dienstag ok verstehe ja so muss das sein aber das
müssen sie alle mal da müssen sie alle durch alle arbeitgeber müssen da jetzt mal durch
also auch wenn ihr aktuellen job habt wo ihr nicht wechseln wollt oder so ich meine gibt
da bestimmt auch leute die zufrieden sind mit dem was sie machen einfach ein bisschen
hartnäckig sein ist auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt weil sonst weil sie reden sich ja prinzipiell
eh immer raus mit oh das passt jetzt ganz schlecht oder du hast doch erst was gekriegt
oder blabla blabla blabla blabla es ist vollkommen egal die ausreden ausreden sind immer die
gleichen ja war bei mir auch so lebenslauf lebenslauf skill ist da hat gereicht zeugnisse
habe ich erst danach hochgeladen wo man es eigentlich schon eigentlich waren lohnt sich
noch eine 30 80 für einen casual gamer suche was für die nächsten fünf bis sechs jahre
fünf bis sechs jahre das ist so ein langer zeitraum da musste ja fast 40 90 holen fünf
bis sechs jahre ist wirklich lang er weiß wie sie fünf bis sechs jahre aussieht also
ich habe meinen rechner ziemlich genau fünf jahre jetzt den aktuellen der neue steht hinter
mir und deshalb hat 1080 ti und 8700 k und das ist nach fünf jahren so langsam aber sicher
ist jetzt ist jetzt mal endgelände ich meine die sachen laufen immer noch und wahrscheinlich
sind schneller als was viele leute daheim stehen haben aber wenn du wirklich neue sachen
auch mit richtig guter quali spielen vielleicht auch höheren auflösung da macht es da macht
es eigentlich also fünf bis sechs jahre schon wirklich sehr unüberschaubarer zeitraum für
so was wenn du sagen willst zwei drei jahre kannst du es ohne probleme machen wahrscheinlich
auch noch länger aber ansonsten also wenn du wirklich sicher sein willst dass du fünf
sechs jahre ganz gut mit über die runden kommst dann musst du da bleibt dir nichts
übrig als 40 90 zu kaufen klar für was soll da sonst stehen ja für uns zeugnis zum start
da bin ich mal gespannt wo beantragt man so was überhaupt bei einem amt wahrscheinlich
gut für uns zeugnis wird bei mir recht langweilig sein da steht drauf gibt nix ich habe bisher
keine straftaten begangen und wurde nicht verurteilt also das was soll da drin stehen
ja das geht aber nur wenn das irgendwie auch bei wo davon eingerichtet ist so dass das
fragt mich nicht dass irgendwie mitbekommt und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass wo
davon einfach die s light abschaltet weil der slide funktioniert ja damit nicht und
das ist ja eigentlich ein provider seitliche config also das kann eigentlich miteinander
nichts zu tun haben es sei denn die checken irgendwie die fähigkeiten und dann schalten
sie die slide aus oder was aber ziemlich bescheuert weil die man die machen die s light ja eben
vor yp zu sparen
was hat was hat nvidia mit fifa modding zu tun habe ich überhaupt keinen plan von aber
was hat die grafikkarte mit mit gemoddetem fifa zu tun
sieht fast so aus was steht bei weihnachten bei dir an dazu kann ich bloß eines sagen
pepo fett steht bei mir an mit gefuttert ohne ende wieder ich streame aktuell nicht vom
neuen pc ne mein neuer pc steht seit einer woche hinter mir und fängt staub
außerdem da schon ein paar sachen umgebaut aber jetzt ist er eigentlich fertig ist alles
drin ne ist nicht alles drinne ha ich hab die 10g karte noch vergessen einzubauen bis
jetzt stimmt die muss noch einbauen aber ansonsten ist alles drin
in welchem rad ok ja online ist mir am liebsten mein winkel online ist mir am liebsten wenn
man fifa moddet wird man da nicht online gebannt oder gehts da bloß um offline spiele oder
oder oder kosmetische sachen und könnt mir vorstellen dass wenn du game modst mit anti
cheat dass das das eigentlich nicht so gerne hat gemoddet zu werden aber gut da hab ich
also fifa modding habe ich keinen plan von my app got wrecked so so was verdient ein
becker das interessiert mich was ein becker verdient der macht nix mit holz aber trotzdem
macht auch wichtige sachen
irgendwas drin was ich mir angucken will ich wirklich ja
muss mal kurz was gucken ob ich irgendwelche issues übersehen habe
aha ach es geht rein um offline ja das verstehe ich dann ist ok dann leuchte das ein hast
du lust auf weihnachten ich habe gar keinen bock es ist bin da eigentlich relativ gleichgültig
ob weihnachten ist oder nicht
feels bad man manchmal bin ich froh dass ich weder frau noch kinder und sonst fleffrichtung
in dieser richtung habe
4 hat wieder heile ja schon seit schon seit einigen tagen ist er wieder heile ja ja ich
habe ja mal ein 3 jahre altes auto 33 3 monate altes auto gleich mal kaputt gemacht
was hast du für 10 g karten genommen melanox die die bei ebay 30 euro kosten pci pci express
also vier vier vier wie heißt das vierfach pci express karten
hast du wieder teilzahlen im neuen job ja 80 prozent nach wie vor war weihnachtsfeier
im geschäft ja bin ich aber nicht hin dieses jahr
kündigung schon vorbeigebracht nehme ich nächste woche mache ich mit meinem kollege
zusammen wir kündigen ja beide zum ende des jahres und fangen beide bei der neuen
beim gleichen neuen laden an also kann man auch zusammen die kündigung abgeben wenn
wir schon mal da sind also dual kündigung
ja die hatten zwei stellen frei wir haben uns beworben wir haben uns beide genommen
beziehungsweise eigentlich lief das so eigentlich lief das so ex kollege hat mich angeschrieben
so nach dem motto max wie sieht es aus will es nicht zu uns damit ist ein bisschen erzählt
ich fand das eigentlich ziemlich cool wie sich das angehört hat habe ich mich da beworben
und als ich dort dort war in frankfurt habe ich den lebenslauf von meinem kollege mit
genommen habe gesagt hier ich habe gehört ihr sucht noch mehr leute wie sieht es mit
ihm aus und haben die gesagt oh ja passt er richtig gut und dann haben sie sich ein
tag später bei ihm gemeldet haben gesagt auf geht's kommt zu uns so nice wusstest du
das vorher ich wusste ich wusste dass die zwei drei leute suchen ja also das hat gut
funktioniert wie der full remote gals technisch verbessert also full remote ist ja das was
ich aktuell mache nicht und das neue wird auch nicht full remote sein das neue wird
aber deutlich mehr home office haben weil das ja eigentlich der hauptpunkt ist weshalb
ich überhaupt weg will dort wo ich aktuell bin deutlich mehr home office haben und gals
technisch ist auch ein bisschen besser ach so wo bewerben das sage ich dir nicht ich sage
dir nicht wo ich bin weil es liegt daran ich sage zwar die ganzen dinge die ich hier erzähle
eh schon immer anonymisiert und ein bisschen random meist also die sachen die ich euch
erzähle sind nicht eins zu eins immer exakt so wirklich passiert ich mixe da manchmal
immer ein paar sachen dass es nicht zu auffällig wird und ich sage halt auch nie da wo um welchen
laden das letztendlich geht das heißt ihr wisst nie ob das beim provider war bei meinem
aktuellen arbeitgeber noch früher oder sonst wo also ich erzähle da nichts ich darf ja
auch gar nichts erzählen darf ja auch gar nicht beim neuen muss ich auch schon wieder
geheimhaltungs zeug unterschreiben man weiß es nicht kann sein aber alles was ich bis
jetzt gesehen habe spricht es dafür dass es es gibt überall sachen diese nervig ja
spricht dafür dass es nicht nerviger ist als dort wo ich aktuell bin und die sachen
die mich richtig nerven besser sind ist der text in einer vorlage eigentlich richtig
müsste es nicht heißen dass zum nein die kündigung gebe ich hier ich kündige jetzt
aber gültig ist die erst ab 31 dritten also 31 dritten ist es dann wenn die kündigung
durch ist ist der tag wo ich nicht mehr dorthin muss weil der arbeitsvertrag ausgelaufen
ist oder gekündigt ist 31 dritt das ist richtig was ist mit dem vier hat passiert ich bin
über den bordstein gefahren mit 50 kmh ungefähr und da ist der reifen geplatzt an der seite
und die felge verkratzt und ich habe schon gehofft aber eben nicht gehofft ich habe
schon vermutet die felge ist nicht mehr ganz gerade danach aber ich habe gehofft dass
nix ist ja und es war mit der felge auch nix es war bloß der reifen kaputt nur der reifen
kaputt und bisschen bisschen gekratzt an der felge da kann ich mit leben ganz ehrlich
ich würde das auch also wenn ich leute einstellen würde ich würde auch reinschreiben punkte
was geheimnis geheimnisse und und geheimhaltung und so was angeht klar auch kein bock dass
jeder sich irgendwo ins internet stellen kann alle intern details ausplaudern vielleicht
auch sachen die kritisch sind eine motz eine motz sind bei mir nicht angestellt die müssen
die man das alles freiwillig müssen nix unterschreiben hat der homo system nicht gewarnt
es hat alles gewarnt die app das auto selbst und auch die anzeige im homo system hat gewarnt
dass der reifendruck nicht richtig ist aber ich habe schon gemerkt dass der reifen platt
ist bevor es das wirklich gemeldet hat also man merkt dass ich habe das ich habe das direkt
gemerkt am geräusch dass es nicht nicht mehr exakt so anders wie vorher und das ein bisschen
geruckelt hat so und das hat man irgendwie gemerkt das was mit dem reifen ist ich habe
gehofft ok vielleicht ist ein bisschen bisschen kap beschädigt und nicht aber nee dann ist
direkt ein paar hundert meter weiter habe ich gemerkt die luft raus und dann hat es
auch angefangen zu zu zu warnen ja ja ich habe nie details erzählt ich habe auch nie
erzählt um wen es sich handelt ich habe nur gesagt beispielsweise dass mir einige sachen
auf den keks gegangen sind wie zum beispiel erzwungene wie ist das team building workshops
die keine team building workshops waren nur darum ging die leute schlecht zu machen ja
das habe ich erzählt dass mir das auf den keks ging das ist ja kein geheimnis in dem
sinn dass man ein team building workshop gemacht hat also konunu bewertung weiß ich gerade
noch gar nicht ob ich eine abgebe für meinen alten arbeitgeber also wenn wenn ich da eine
abgebe dann schreibe ich da ganz sachlich rein was sache ist und ich werde jetzt auch
nicht super schlecht bewerten oder so weil die sind ja nicht super schlecht es gibt
halt ein paar sachen die mir die mich nerven ja mag jemand anderes nicht so sehen sie
könnten ein bisschen mehr bezahlen ja das haben wir gar nicht der hauptsächliche punkt
gewesen ich bin mit der kohle auch so locker ausgekommen aber hauptsächlich hier hin und
her was home office angeht ging mir halt wirklich auf den sack ich meine muss ich das mal vorstellen
sind sogar leute drauf umgezogen hin auf die ursprüngliche ankündigung und dann wurde
wieder komplett rückwärtsgang eingelegt dazu ich habe was gefunden ich habe den vertrag
hier liegen ja ab ersten vierten geht es dann los
euer easy würde ich auch machen ohne scheiß leute das würde ich sofort machen wenn mir
mein chef auf der aktuellen arbeit anbietet geht auch gleich wir bezahlen dir weiter gelten
du musst nicht mehr arbeiten sofort würde ich sofort machen warum sollte ich das nicht
machen die werden aber entteufelt tun die werden mich keinen tag früher gehen lassen
wäre ich sofort dabei war home office für dich bereits vor corona wichtig ja allerdings
während der corona zeit wurde es dann auch großflächig möglich war noch mehr möglich
war als vorher habe ich erst mal gesehen also was heißt nicht erst mal gesehen hat mich
das noch mal bestätigt drin dass das das beste ist was es gibt zum arbeiten sowohl
von dem was man schafft also alles andere ist es für alle besser ist für mich besser
für euch besser und es für den arbeitgeber besser ist für alle besser ja das wird ausgeglichen
dadurch dass ich wieder irgendwelche fake bewertungen von irgendwelchen leuten reingesetzt
werden das ist manche manche bewertungen das so ob wir es fake bei koh uno machst du weiter
in der fob stuff korrekt es ist es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so weit weg von dem was ich jetzt
mache ich mein was ich genau aber im neuen job mache so exakt im detail weiß ich natürlich
nicht da muss man muss ich das ich meine nur weil man die tools kennt die jemand verwenden
heißt dass man weiß wie er die genau benutzt aber im prinzip so ein großer unterschied
ist es gar nicht
dass die soll mich die können mich freistellen bin ich sofort dabei wenn die mich freistellen
aber es wird nicht passieren weil alle anderen die ich mitbekommen habe die dort gekündigt
haben die wurs die mussten bis zum letzten tag ich kenne sogar einen der hat schicht
der hat der macht schichtarbeit und er hat seine letzte schicht ohne scheiß er hat seine
letzte schicht am 31 12 und zum 1 1 ist hat er ist er weg und wir haben wir haben uns schon
drüber drüber lustig gemacht ob die zeit erfassung des beim ausstechen dann checkt
wenn er nachts wenn er morgens um 5 quasi aussticht obwohl er eigentlich ja schon gekündigt
hat so schon gespannt was da rauskommt na klar es geht auch nicht darum dass wir banker
bist in der it und gerade systeme die da außen dienst verwendet oder endkunden gar verwenden
das ist die urzeit ziemlich egal ja das hast du glück ich finde das ist auch tatsächlich
der beste ansatz ja wenn nicht so sehr auf die ganzen sachen drumherum geguckt wird sondern
einfach geschaut wird ob die leute was können und die sache ordentlich machen und gut ist
ich kenne auch jemand hat er mir eins zu eins zu erzählen der hat gesagt ihm gehen daheim
die frau und die kinder offen kicks deswegen der will kein homeoffice machen der will
unbedingt nach frankfurt auf die arbeit fahren das ist doch ok also ich bin der meinung man
sollte es den leuten ja durchaus also wenn das jeweilige unternehmen denn noch arbeitsplätze
hat und nicht rein remote es gibt ja auch mittlerweile einige man sollte das den leuten
auf jeden fall ermöglichen wenn die das wollen aber umgedreht sollte man es auch den ermöglichen
dieses nicht wollen zumindest das zu reduzieren ja so ganz so ganz nie ins büro verstehe
ich wenn man das nicht will aber jetzt aber das zu reduzieren das wäre schon wäre schon
sehr sinnig wenn man einfach den leuten das die wahl lässt ich finde wichtig ist dass
beide seiten dann bisschen flexibel sind ja also zum beispiel wenn ich achte ich arbeite
ja nur teilzeit 80 prozent sagen wir mal ich bin montags aktuell ist es ja so montags
bin ich immer nicht da so aber wenn mal irgendwelche abteilungsrunden oder sonst was sind wo ich
irgendwas vorstellen will was vorstellen soll weil ich wieder so blöd war mich freiwillig
dafür zu melden dann gehe ich da trotzdem hin so das ist das erwarte ich dann umgedreht
aber halt auch ich bin in so fallen flexibel und macht das und wenn dann halt mal was in
der andere richtung ist dann dann würde ich das dann auch erwarten dass man das dünner
also ordentlich hand haben kann ja und nicht auf dann drauf pocht so muss das aber sein
also es ist am besten wenn man das die leuten ermöglichen so wie sie es machen wollen
das wird bei mir nicht so sein mein vertrag läuft wenn ich jetzt kündige mein vertrag
läuft bis zum 31 dritten und ich werde bis zum 31 dritten arbeiten müssen das sage
ich euch so wie es ist das war auch bei allen anderen die ich kenne so die von sich aus
gekündigt haben ja die leute die gekündigt wurden da war das auch so alle alle das wird
bis zum letzten tag wird werden die wollen dass ich dort arbeite kann ich euch jetzt
gebe ich euch brief und siegel drauf ich hätte gar keine schmerzen mit wenn die sagen hey
hau ab wir bezahlen die aber noch weiter gehalt da wäre ich sofort dabei
das hier ist mein letzter arbeitstag dort und hier fange ich dann bei den neuen an
hier oder hier was energy sein alter arbeitgeber hatte so eine schlechte bewertung und da hat
das alles gepasst was ja ich gucke mir die bewertung ja auch immer an und ich vieles
von denen erkenne ich da auch wieder ja du hast eine zweite ausbildung als physik angefangen
ja was ist das erste was du gelernt hast wahrscheinlich was ganz was andere schlosser oder so random
ich habe jetzt einfach mal irgendwas gesagt ok der alchemist sagt jetzt mal ehrlich der
grund dass man eher im büro bleiben sollte wegen der verbesserten team dynamik und so
geht es da jetzt wirklich ums geld oder ums prinzip da zu sein weil der chef nicht will
dass man für zuhause chill das kommt auf den chef an gerade die etwas älteren semester
was das angeht die haben so ein bisschen probleme nicht nur die nicht nur dein direkter chef
auch viele manager haben also ein bisschen das problem wenn die nicht sehen dass jemand
was macht dann denken sie standardmäßig dass der nix macht zumindest habe ich den eindruck
dass umso älter die manager sind umso verbreitet er das ganze ist allerdings ist der witz halt
dass die auch überhaupt nicht einschätzen können wie wenn wann jemand wirklich was
macht also nur weil jemand am computer sieht angestrengt aussieht und tippt heißt es ja
noch lange nicht dass der grad was sinnvolles macht also die gleichen können es auch gar
nicht mal richtig einschätzen denken aber dass sie es können und die dies richtig einschätzen
können die haben dann meistens kein problem damit auch zu sagen so lange eure arbeit macht dann
kommt halt kommt halt nur einmal die woche oder zweimal die woche bei mir einmal die woche weil
einmal die woche beste einmal die woche finde ich gut da kann man mal furtern gehen man kann die
teamrunde an dem tag machen und ansonsten kriegt man daheim schlichtergreifend mehr geschafft
ne was sie machen können ist ihm einfach die stunden nach nur nicht mehr gut schreiben dann
müsste er sich ja irgendwie rumstreiten mit denen ich frag mich nicht wie die genaue regelung da ist
also die schicht endet um fünf Uhr morgens und die haben da irgendwas ausgemacht dass
er die schicht auch bis zum schluss macht obwohl er bis am ende des jahres gekündigt hat fragt
mich nicht wie die das geregelt haben bin ich bin mal ich bin mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
wir haben hier ein paar im chat die angeblich 100 prozent remote arbeiten ja habe ich schon öfters
gehört kann ich auch verstehen wie gesagt kenne ich auch leute deswegen denke ich man sollte dass
die leuten einfach ermöglichen dort zu arbeiten wo es wo sie am besten arbeiten können bei mir
ist es eindeutig daheim das habe ich einfach auch gemerkt im direkten vergleich jetzt gerade in
letzter zeit wo ich wieder zweimal die woche da da gewesen bin ich habe in den tagen so gut
wie nix geschafft bekommen daheim easy zumal ich auch viel wacher bin allein und deswegen kriege
ich besser sachen geschafft ja viel mehr zeit und das ganze gependel ist hat man sich erspart es
ist für alle besser aber ja klar natürlich wenn einer daheim sitzt mit kinder die nervig sind
frau die rumrennt küschen dich kein richtiges büro dann verstehe ich deswegen man sollte es den
leuten einfach ermöglichen dort wo es am besten funktioniert ist am endeffekt für die leute
ist besser und für die firma auch die kriegen dann quasi für ihr geld mehr
ja drei monate zum quartal deswegen muss ich hier bis spätestens nächste woche ja also bis
heute nächste woche muss ich also plan ist entweder dienstag oder mittwoch abgeben ja
es ist zum quartal und dann drei monate das heißt würde ich am 1. januar kündigen wäre
ich erst am 1. siebten weg deswegen deswegen war ich jetzt ja auch so unter zugzwang dass
das bis ende des jahres noch was wird
ja ist schon was dran zumal es überhaupt kein problem ist wenn man auf dem zweiten
bildschirm reddit auf hat ich habe beispielsweise auf dem handy immer irgendwie in den stream
laufen oder so ich gucke da nicht aktiv drauf jetzt irgendwie zwei stunden am tag auf der
arbeit ich lasse es nebenbei laufen weil ich einfach viel besser arbeiten kann wenn ich
was auf dem ohr habe irgendwas bekannt ist irgend einer der was spielt im hintergrund
irgendwie den soundtrack den ich den ich gern höre das ist besser als besser als büro sound
ist besser als ich höre den typ der telefoniert an der sich aufregt irgendeiner der mich voll
labern will ich setz die kopfhörer auf mache den livestream an macht das handy auf background
also man sperren den sperren den bildschirm lasse den stream background laufen und höre
dann zu manchmal gucke ich auch irgendwelche votes an also ich höre mir irgendwelche votes
an ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass ich da nie draufgucke oder so klar gucke ich da ab
und zu einmal drauf aber ich habe das eigentlich eher so als als hintergrund rauschen
welche hobbies hast du im lebenslauf angegeben ich hatte gar keine hobbies drin ich habe
einen weil ich einen punkt gehabt irgendwie sonstiges oder oder weiteres oder irgendwie
sowas in der richtung und da habe ich reingeschrieben dass ich selbstständig also neben beruflich
selbstständiger web video produzent bin und dass ich open source projekte auf github
hab und sowas in der richtung weiß gar nicht was ich da noch reingeschrieben habe ich
glaube das war es aber hobbies habe ich nicht reingeschrieben die haben mich gefragt im
vorstellungsgespräch nach hobbies gesagt ich gehe gerne wandern und beschäftigt mich
viel mit heim automatisierung da hatten wir es dann von meinem open source projekt vom
elektroauto hat ja wirklich gut dazu gepasst dass ich das reingeschrieben habe aber ich
hatte keine sektion hobbies interessiert wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich oder man vielleicht wenn
man sonst gar nicht weiß wie derjenige tickt ja aber korrekt ja sehe ich auch so
der will das geld haben der will nun nicht um nur nur ausstempeln ja da machst du nix
da machst du kein home office aber wobei ist halt die frage ob die sich in ruhe lassen
wenn die tür zu ist tür zu abschließen und mal gucken ob es dann nervig ist kommt ein
bisschen drauf an vielleicht noch die frau daheim oder so je nachdem aber ja klar was
gut aber vier wenn du vier kinder daheim hast die daheim rumtouren irgendwie man musste
sich ja darum kümmern wenn er auf der arbeit ist also ja aber verstehe schon dass es nicht
immer geht du hast damals vor vier jahren zerspanungsmechaniker gelernt was macht man
als zerspa ich kann mir da jetzt gar nichts darunter vorstellen zerspäne also ich das
hört sich noch fräsen oder so an metal bearbeitung irgendwie so c und c fräse und so was habe
dann die letzten vier jahre beim alten arbeitgeber gearbeitet in drei schichten und die ausbildung
ist wie sie läuft bei mir jetzt echt super auch wenn es lust mit 22 quatsch macht dir
nichts draus mit viel ich war auch mit 24 in der berufsschule ich habe 2007 wie alt
war ich in 2007 23 23 24 24 war ich war genauso alt wie du als ich die ausbildung angefangen
habe ich habe davor auch was anderes versucht versucht mich in anderen sachen versucht
ja wie ihr seid 28 schüler und ihr seid 60 leute wir jetzt wie könnt ihr 28 60 wird
jetzt verstehe aber berufsschule ist easy as fuck wenn man ein bisschen plan hat ja wenn
ich nur zwölf minuten hätte hätte ich auch weniger probleme aber ich muss mit der bahn
nach frankfurt fahren und bahnreisen sind immer so ein ding für so eine sache für
sich ihr kennt meine twitter pause was passiert eigentlich wenn man gar nicht zur arbeit geht
und von sich aus kündigt was wäre da eine rechtliche konsequenz wie zum beispiel die
können nicht die können nicht sonderkündigen arbeitsverweigerung oder sowas könnten sie
wahrscheinlich machen aber gut wenn du weg willst kriegst dann halt wahrscheinlich ziemlich
mieses zeugnis ok drops hat eine dumme frage zeigt mal her wie blöd die frage wirklich
ist ich habe zwei urls beide dns einstellungen sind gleich die eine url wird vom dns-server
aufgelöst die andere nicht hast du eine idee jetzt so mal auf nummer sicher zu gehen du
hast zwei zweimal die url reingeschrieben und die sollen zur gleichen ip auflösen
ja sehe ich das richtig das aber im prinzip nicht so kompliziert also da kannst du eigentlich
gar nicht so viel verkehrt machen zwei dns namen zur gleichen ip ist überhaupt kein
problem umgedreht ist ein bisschen komplizierter zwei ip zum gleichen name geht nicht was
für dns verwendest du denn ich weiß wenn du irgendwie was in der fritzbox eingebaut
es verwendest oder so da kann ich mir das durchaus vorstellen dass da vielleicht damit
problem hat aber normalerweise ist das ein vollkommen legit setup du willst ja zum beispiel
dass keine ahnung wupplos.tv und ww.wupplos.tv auf dem gleichen system rauskommt also muss
da eigentlich ohne probleme gehen kann das auch mit weiterleitung machen das geht auch
noch netcup netcup habe ich noch nie verwendet
wir hatten auch einen in der berufsschule der war auch schon deutlich älter war wahrscheinlich
so alt damals wie ich jetzt lego dankeschön für den sub korrekt nein noch nicht noch
nicht noch nicht mache ich nächste woche nächste woche nächste woche dienstag wahrscheinlich
den neuen vertrag habe ich schon hier liegen jetzt kam mit der post ja nächste woche
ja ich denke auch dass es nie zur gerade in der heutigen zeit guck mal es gibt so viele
leute die vielleicht jetzt in einem job arbeiten entweder wusste in zukunft so in der in dem
umfang gar nicht mehr geben wird oder die einfach festgestellt haben das ist nichts
für sie sie wollen was anderes machen haben vielleicht sich schon immer für computer
it netzwerk und so was interessiert ist nie zu spät eine ausbildung zu machen und gerade
im it bereich heute es werde hände regeln werden leute gesucht immer natürlich schützt
sich das nicht davor vor dem was ich immer sage ausbildung alleine bringt hier nichts
ein bisschen ahnung musst du auch haben aber aktuell ist it technisch wirklich easy so
easy wie noch nie was zu bekommen und dementsprechend auch ein bisschen kohle sich das auch gut bezahlen
zu lassen du hast ein ubiquity router ausgetauscht gegen den mikrotrick nur halb so schlimm
wie ich dachte für 8 euro bekommt man ein echt dickes bretter ja also router os features
ist mit das beste preisleistungstechnik was ich kenne ja die bedienung ist busy ja und
das kommando zeilen tool ist auch jetzt man kommt damit klar ja die an also das ist das
ist hier leihwerk ist mir da ich finde ich schon klarer gemacht aber das ist wirklich
super also kann sich nicht beschweren mikrotrick ist preisleistungstechnik einfach der hammer
die teile ja zum beispiel da habe ich noch gar nicht dran gedacht klar könnte ja auch
sein jemand der wie ich habe euch doch mal erzählt ich hatte berufsschulen jemand ähnlichen
ja der war steinmetz ihm ist irgendwas auf den fuß gefallen so dass er quasi nicht
mehr als steinmetz arbeiten kann hat jetzt fachinformatiker gelernt es ist der der 2
von 100 punkten in der datenbank arbeit hatte dem hat es nicht wirklich gelegen ja irgendeine
platte ist ihm auf den fuß gefallen und leute ich kann mir ich kann es nur ansatzweise vorstellen
dass das wirklich sehr schmerzhaft sein muss weil ich habe mitbekommen dass damals bei
einem rechenzentrum umzug jemand der dabei war als jemand aus meinem team damals dem
ist ein dl 380 mit vollen platten eher eher gen 6 oder so wird das gewesen sein dem ist
so ein ding mit voll voll beladen mit platten aus der hand gerutscht und auf den fuß gefallen
beim umzug von einem rechenzentrum so ein teil eher gen 7 würde ich sagen was hier so
was hier in der richtung das ist schon das ist schon ein bisschen was also ich würde
mal sagen voll beladen wiegt das durchaus mal so 35 kilo und da hatte keine sicherheitsschuhe
oder sowas an ich meine wer zieht sich bei einem rechenzentrums umzug schon sicherheitsschuhe
auch wenn es nicht besser wenn es besser wäre das machen würde der war dann zwei wochen
erst mal außer gefechter das hat wen kann ich mir vorstellen wenn die sogar so eine
fette steinplatte drauf fällt die noch ein bisschen mehr wiegt das willst du nicht verschmeißt
den dl 380 aus denn es ist ja nicht so als hat er absichtlich gesagt ach ja ach ja ich
werfe man den server jetzt auf mein fuß wahrscheinlich ist er gestolpert oder es war irgendwas im
weg oder so ich meine das aber bestimmt nicht so einfach mal just for fun wie ist denn das
so wenn einem der server auf den fuß fällt ich probiere das jetzt mal aus ja es gibt
playcenter sind auch richtig fette schwere dinger also mein traum ist es ja immer noch
mal auszuprobieren wie schnell so ein playcenter werden kann rein mit lüfter also ich würde
ich würde gerne mal so ein altes IBM playcenter und alt ist ein altes teil also da träume
ich ja schon lange von dass man wirklich auf gut gelagerte rollen stellen so auf inline
skates rollen zum beispiel oder inline skates drunter schnallen oder rollschuhe drunter
schnallen und dann 100 prozent leistung also 100 prozent lüfter ich würde einfach gerne
mal wissen wie schnell kann so ein ding werden ja ich weiß stromzufuhr ist ein bisschen
schwierig da muss dann einer nebenher rennen mit dem stromkabel aber so ein paar kmh schafft
das ding schon die lüfter sind wirklich heftig also wenn ihr hinter ich weiß ich wäre von
euch schon mal das verklügen hatte hinter so einem IBM playcenter knien zu dürfen wenn
es 100 prozent lüfter leistung gerade fährt also ihr müsst euch wirklich aktiv dagegen
lehnen dass es euch nicht zurück bläst also wenn ihr davor kniet ihr kniet beispielsweise
hinten im gang im rechenzentrum kniet ihr nicht im ding das hat 100 prozent cpu last
aber was weiß ich ihr patcht irgendwas daneben oder so und ihr kniet da so auf den auf den
in der hocke ja ihr müsst euch wirklich nach vorne lehnen dass ihr nicht zurück umfällt
also die dinge haben 100 prozent 100 prozent lüfter haben die schon ganz schön ganz schön
zug das hat auch keine auf youtube probiert das habe ich letzten schon mal geguckt als
letztes auch wieder zwei jahre her oder so playcenter auf rollen auch keiner ausprobiert
es wäre wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht gewesen hätte er damals auch ordentliche arbeitsschuhe
angehabt
das kann auch sein letztendlich hat er bestimmt nicht absichtlich den server runter geschmissen
ob es dem server noch gut ging ich vermute mal dass dem nicht allzu viel passiert ist
wenn einem das war aus der handrutsche auf dem fußfeld es knallt zwar aber die dinger
sind recht stabil vielleicht ist eine festplatte drin aber wahrscheinlich ist dem server gar
nichts passiert
auch da gibt es bestimmt ein paar in die alte dl 3 18 abstellkammer stehen haben
selbst schuld also ich wusste mal mit phoenix zusammen in playcenter einbauen und richtig
fettes so ungefähr so auf brusthöhe das war schon riesenakt man
playcenter lüfter im betrieb ok
ja das ist wie gesagt es ist wie ein flugzeug was startet das ding
ja so ist das so ist das bei den dinger
die lüfter sind brutal ja das sind richtig heftige dinger
ich habe gesagt dass der server noch ging ja dann wird es wohl auch gewesen sein also
ich kann mich jetzt nicht mehr bildlich daran erinnern aber ich gehe stark von aus dass
der noch geht sowas muss in ein pc bauen
playcenter lüfter sind jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel viel schwächer
so leute heute machen wir kurz ein stream ich hatte eigentlich vor dass wir heute google
cloud und polumi zeug weitermachen das haben wir morgen früh so so ein bisschen technik
kram vor heilig abend muss doch sein das machen wir morgen früh oder oder sagen wir morgen
nach mittag essen oder irgendwie sowas das machen wir morgen auf jeden fall noch weihnachts
cloud config gibt es noch irgendwas wichtiges habe ich
irgendwas vergessen chat gibt es so irgendwelche wichtigen
sachen jetzt gehe ich noch nicht schlafen wobei 21
Uhr fast fast bettgeteim hast du schon antwort antwort von der personalabteilung bezüglich
job ja ich habe den neuen verdrag hier liegen hier wo ist er
ane oben auf dem schrank legt er ich hatte den bis eben hier liegen
ok leute bis morgen machts gut kurzer stream heute anders gelaufen als geplant wir sehen
uns bis denn zu keine ahnung